[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de medio
ambiente en france24 yo soy maría clara
calle la gran noticia ambiental del
momento es la ola de calor en europa se
han difundido imágenes de pavimentos
derritiéndose o de personas nadando
desesperadas en el agua pero más allá de
eso la ola de calor tiene dos
consecuencias graves para el planeta el
incremento de incendios y la
contaminación por ozono empecemos por
hablar de qué tan grave es lo que está
pasando y es que por primera vez las
temperaturas en reinounido superaron los
40 grados celsius y las autoridades
emitieron la primera alerta roja por el
clima de la historia mientras que
portugal han muerto más de 1000 personas
por estos temperaturas extremas y españa
supera temperaturas de 46 grados en el
aire y la temperatura del suelo es
todavía más alta copernicus que es el
observatorio de la unión europea ha
reportado casi 60 grados en el suelo
español y cerca de 50 en francia- lo que
explica por qué algunos pavimentos se
están derritiendo
es normal que haya olas de calor extremo
por los patrones del clima el problema
es que ahora son más frecuentes duran
más y son más intensas y el responsable
de esto es el calentamiento global
europa está viviendo el promedio de
temperatura más alto que se haya visto
en 100 años según la convención marco de
la onu sobre cambio climático y en junio
de este año se registró la segunda
temperatura media mensual más alta en la
historia del viejo continente una de las
consecuencias más notorias son los
incendios forestales
por ejemplo la península ibérica donde
están portugal y españa- atraviesa las
condiciones más secas que ha tenido en
mil años por esto a finales de julio
españa y también francia reino unido e
italia han enfrentado el peligro de
conflagración es más alto de todos con
la categoría de muy extremo según
copernicus en tan sólo diez días se
quemaron más de 40 mil hectáreas por
otra parte de las temperaturas extremas
y los incendios repercuten en la
contaminación la organización
meteorológica mundial explica que la ola
de calor está funcionando como una tapa
que atrapa los contaminantes en la
atmósfera esto hace que se forme el
ozono muy cerca de la superficie
especialmente en el oeste y en el sur de
europa como lo muestra el mapa si bien
cuando el ozono está en la estratosfera
nos protege de los rayos del sol cuando
está más cerca de la tierra contribuye a
la contaminación del aire lo que impacta
en la salud de los humanos y de las
plantas en resumen las olas de calor son
más extremas y más frecuentes por el
calentamiento global y a su vez las
altas temperaturas contribuyen a la
crisis climática y lo que ocurre en
europa pasará cada vez más seguido
lezcano hitler en el futuro este tipo de
velas de calor serán normales y veremos
extremos aún más fuertes al vivir su
versión de streams vía bullrich
ya hemos lanzado tanto dióxido de
carbono a la atmósfera que la tendencia
negativa continuará durante las próximas
décadas y hasta ahora no hemos sido
capaces de reducir nuestras emisiones en
el mundo emisión global y precisamente
reducir las emisiones contaminantes es
el objetivo de la cob 27 que será en
noviembre en egipto allí cada país
presentará sus metas renovadas para
alcanzar dicho propósito y previo la
copa en cada región se realizan semanas
del clima para discutir las acciones
climáticas esta vez fue el turno de
américa latina y el caribe entre el 18 y
el 22 de julio república dominicana
acogió a líderes empresarios y a la
sociedad civil en france 24 hablamos con
the nation conservas y con el fondo de
aguas de santo domingo quienes resaltan
la importancia de vincular al sector
productivo
la experiencia para nosotros el ver como
la alianza público-privada realmente ha
podido concretar el mirón estos actores
del mismo el cine que en la continuación
de los ejercicios pinturas del aula por
supuesto sin el sector privado realmente
el gobierno no va a poderlo hacer solos
ni tampoco la sociedad civil por eso es
importante el empresariado empresarial o
consciente y nosotros estamos aquí en el
fundo de mando de dominó para poder
ayudar a ese empresariado a generar
estrategias de negocios que sean
rentables
pero incluyendo transversalizando los
temas de sostenibilidad los temas
ambientales y por supuesto porque nobel
de cambio climático porque normalmente
estos programas que ya predecían estas
estrategias pues son muy interesantes
pero si no podemos llevar estos
programas a la acción entonces realmente
estamos haciendo turismo son cosas creo
que las empresas están muy conscientes
de que deben actuar de que deben alomar
recursos específicos
no es exagerado decir que américa latina
y el caribe es uno de los pulmones del
mundo y es que la región está el 57% de
los bosques primarios que quedan en el
planeta pero también es uno de los
lugares más afectados por la crisis
climática el 30 por ciento de la
población vive en áreas costeras y
enfrentan la pérdida de sus playas por
la erosión las inundaciones y la
violencia cada vez mayor de los
huracanes por eso la región es clave de
cara a la cob 27 de américa latina
patricia to coincidirá conmigo la verdad
que es una de las regiones más vibrantes
y de mayor crecimiento pero también que
tienen grandes bosques y puede hacer
muchos aportes sin terminología américa
latina pero como hablamos del caribe
programa de la región que más está
sufriendo los impactos climáticos la
atención que todos necesitamos así es yo
creo que nosotros lo que podemos jugar
es la experiencia que hemos han sido
precisamente por los combates hemos
recibido durante años de fenómenos
hidrometeorológicos extremos
precisamente por los efectos del cambio
climático y las inversiones que hemos
tenido que hacer como estado en ciudad y
como país del caribe para poder atender
y darles respuesta a las necesidades que
que hemos visto con estos embates que
hemos recibido del cambio climático yo
creo que hemos aprendido esto
experiencia nos ha ayudado a ser más
resilientes y podemos poder porque no
parte de lo que nosotros hemos aprendido
de estas lecciones aprendidas a
disposición del resto de latinoamérica y
de los estados que están aquí con
nosotros hasta aquí la crónica de medio
ambiente sigan con nosotros